last night I saw something that I never
thought I would ever see on American
soil it was the stuff of tin-pot
dictator Zin banana republics as you
probably know throughout the entire
country our protests against police
brutality and systemic unfairness and
racism so of course because this is 2020
the thing that was used to fight those
protesting that unfairness and brutality
was yet more unfairness and brutality I
never thought I would ever see anything
like what happened last night in America
what I saw last night was a threat to
our democracy not foreign but domestic a
violation of rights of freedoms and of
laws by the very people who are supposed
to protect and execute those laws
Lafayette Square is a place that I know
very very well
I worked downtown for years and I would
often go to Lafayette Park for a coffee
or to have lunch outside and it's a
beautiful park right in front of the
White House it's also the site of many
protests there are actually protests
there basically 365 days a year there
are people who literally camp out in
tents and given its proximity to the
White House it makes sense as one of the
clear protest sites of choice there have
been protests there for decades if not
literally hundreds of years and while
President Trump was giving a speech
about domination he gave the order to
clear out all of the protesters who were
at and in front of Lafayette Park
President Trump speech began shortly
after 6:00 p.m. he gave the order to
clear out the park at 6:35 p.m. it was a
site of a peaceful protest not all of
these protests have been peaceful but
the one in Lafayette Park was it was
attended by peaceful protesters by the
media as we speak
I am dispatching thousands and thousands
of heavily armed soldiers military
personnel and law enforcement officers
to stop the rioting looting vandalism
assault and the wanton destruction of
property and it's 6:35 p.m. he gave the
order to round everyone up to clear them
out and someone whether it was the
president or those acting under his
orders tear gassed the protesters shot
them with rubber munitions and generally
just beat the [ __ ] out
federal officers armed to the teeth
wearing protective riot gear dressed in
all black clad with plastic shields and
backed up by what was effectively
cavalry on horses began rounding
everyone up and pushing them out this
was the sort of tactic that was designed
to get violent years of study of crowd
control have shown that the way to
de-escalate a situation like this is
effectively to do the exact opposite and
yet these federal officers wearing riot
gear effectively tried to bum rush out
peaceful protesters they came out
swinging literally there's a video
circulating of what one of these federal
officers did to an Australian news crew
after running towards the protesters
this particular officer started punching
and using his shield as a weapon he hits
the Australian cameraman directly in the
stomach beats him up sends him on his
way we have video footage not only of
what one of the protesters saw happening
to this Australian camera crew but also
from the camera crew itself they dealt
with my cameraman team
what was the reason for expelling these
peaceful protesters who were exercising
their constitutional right to protest
the president wanted a photo-op at a
church across the street he wanted to be
able to walk from the White House out
the front door which is rarely done
through Lafayette Park to stand in front
of st. John's Church a nonpartisan place
of worship reports are that little to no
warning was given to the protesters
ahead of time and that it was
coordinated so that he could end his
speech in the Rose Garden and walk
directly out to the church I'm going to
pay my respects to a very very special
place thank you very much
of course when he got to the church for
his photo opportunity he turned his back
on the church he didn't pray he didn't
reflect he didn't even open the Bible he
carried with him he took it out held it
upside down moved it around in different
ways to get the best photo opportunity
stood in front of the church for a
minute or two told the media that it was
a Bible
and then left he cleared out the
protesters before the 7:00 p.m. DC
curfew went into effect and then in the
ultimate irony the president of law and
order stayed past the curfew to get his
photo-op and of course the cherry on top
is that after the crowd was being
dispersed the federal government
employed military Black Hawk helicopters
in a show of force
flying dozens of feet above the crowd in
an incredibly dangerous maneuver that I
can't recall anything like it ever
happening on American soil nothing about
the President's speech or his photo
opportunity was about reconciliation
about progress about repair or even
about amelioration or de-escalation of
the protests it was calculated only to
inflame to make things worse to own the
libs while desecrating a religious site
while blaspheming the Bible and beating
the protesters and we saw the end result
of this callous move this morning just
mere hours after it happened the White
House releases a video montage set to
music the next day a campaign stunt
brought to you by tear gassing some
people like Scott Walker had the
audacity to say that no one else would
have the guts to do what President Trump
did to walk out in front of the crowd
yeah it sure takes a real man to order
other people with guns to fire munitions
at civilians American citizens
exercising their constitutional right to
protest and then walk between a hundred
armed guards and Secret Service members
for a two-minute photo-op after clearing
the area real guts now I've been
referring to these armed guards as
federal officers because all reports
show that these were not DC cops
DC police generally know how to do crowd
control and while we all have issues
with the DC Police Department the
Metropolitan Police Department I'd like
to think that DC cops wouldn't stand for
being puppets of the President so he can
get a photo-op while infringing on
people's constitutional right
apparently the DC police were given
minimal notice they were surprised as
everyone else and one of the ultimate
ironies of this whole situation is that
not only were the DC police totally
uninformed about this maneuver but one
of the priests who is one of the
proprietors of st. John's Church where
the president wanted to have his photo
opportunity was expelled from the area
so the president could stand there mayor
Bowser
the mayor of DC confirmed that nothing
in this particular situation warranted
the use of munitions against the
protesters or the tactics of the riot
police what we saw was before the curfew
time munitions were released on people
who didn't seem to have provoked any
attack and all of the people in this
particular area of DC were in fact
peacefully protesting on this channel I
try to give both sides when there are
both sides to a story there usually are
and in this particular case yes there
were looting and riots in other parts of
the country but they weren't at the
White House no one is supporting the
rioters and the looters but that's not
what was going on here and it could also
be the case that there are bad faith
rioters and protesters and looters who
are part of an otherwise peaceful
protest that's not the issue here the
issue here is that unequivocally
draconian tactics were used on peaceful
protesters before curfew started the
stories about the violent protests and
the unlawful looting and rioting deserve
their own place on the front page of the
New York Times but those stories as of
today deserve to be at the bottom of the
front page because the headline that
should be ringing in every house in
America is that the President of the
United States ordered draconian measures
to expel peaceful protesters so he could
get a photo-op I don't know if it's
possible to overdose on metaphors but
today is actually election day in DC I
don't know something about this whole
situation feels different to me on many
different fronts maybe there are more
cameras out today than in the past and
maybe we're just seeing more of what was
already there and I'm sure that's the
case
but I also wonder if there is more
police abuse that we're seeing as well
when you declare war on America what you
get is a war on America that when you
have federal officers and police dress
up like soldiers they start acting like
soldiers I think in part what we're
seeing today is the result of years of
the president's statements like if you
have a suspect in custody feel free to
rough them up don't be too nice on them
the press is the enemy of the people and
that we need to dominate protesters
making no distinction between looters
and peaceful protesters words have
consequences
the president has a bully pulpit and we
shouldn't be surprised when people
actually follow the words of an
authority figure like the President of
the United States even though I am a
relatively new adopter of the city of
Washington DC as their home I have
adopted it I chose to live here it's my
home and is where I'm gonna stay DC is a
city that has been scarred by the 1968
riots in many ways it's only in the last
say ten years that it's really begun to
heal and I have seen nothing in the last
24 to 48 hours that has done anything to
make things better and the actions that
were taken today threaten that fragile
peace it threatens DC sovereignty as it
were DC is not a state we don't have a
governor often the city can't refuse
federal troops and we don't have the
representatives the senators the
governors and all of the other
privileges that the other states have to
be able to fight the federal government
in the way that they can this is one of
the reasons why DC statehood is so
important
just yesterday morning in those naive
days I was reading an opinion piece by
noted conservative pundit George F will
he wrote in The Washington Post starting
by referring to the president's tweets
about Joe Scarborough stating those who
think are unhinged president's recent
mania about a murder two decades ago
that never happened
represents his moral nadir have missed
the lessons of his life there is no such
thing as rock bottom so assume that the
worst is yet to come I read those words
and I honestly thought that George Will
was overreacting I thought it was a
little histrionic and then of course
because it's 20/20 we all have to eat
our own words and then Lafayette Park
happened yesterday the president said I
am your president of law and order this
is a president who just weeks ago
abdicated all federal responsibilities
regarding kovaydin the coronavirus
calling it a states rights issue and
that the governor should do something
about it and now when it suits him he
aggrandize himself control of all of the
federal officers and the military so
that he can do a photo opportunity if a
city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend the
life and property of their residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for them and he abuses the authority of
the military this is the kind of show of
force that actually escalates into more
violence which is obviously exactly what
some people want now things can and will
get better it might not feel like it but
police shootings nationally are down and
going lower shootings of unarmed people
are going down and accountability is
going up but for things to get better
we're going to have to be proactive
about it and I have to admit that it's
even hard for me an eternal optimist to
be optimistic about the things that I'm
saying on TV
last night today and probably tomorrow
but what can we do
well first record everything if you're
going to take to the streets do so
peacefully and please stop the looters
civil disobedience not only exists to
fight the government itself but also to
fight your fellow men when they're being
unreasonable and if you are going out
please wear masks I really really hope
we're out of the woods with respect to
cope it but this could turn bad we might
have to go into quarantine again
I'm truly conflicted because I think a
lot of this cause is just and it's
fighting injustice but the consequences
are real so please be responsible for
yourself and with respect to other
protesters do what you can to not only
protect them but to protect other
people's property and to record
injustice wherever you see it and to
publish it so that we have at least a
record of it to the members of the armed
citizens who may be asked to turn their
weapons against other American citizens
I ask you to reflect and think about
your actions before you take them that
the highest form of civil disobedience
is to reject an unlawful order and you
may be asked to do so it's not fair but
we all have to play the hands that were
dealt and that unfortunately the federal
military is probably going to be the tip
of the spear on this and the same goes
for the DC Police Department the
Metropolitan Police Department you don't
have to do what we're seeing officers on
TV do there's always a choice and for
everyone else continue speaking out I am
continually astonished by the outpouring
of support that people have given to
this cause and and rightfully so and
we're of course hearing from the usual
suspects it's no surprise the people
that are in support of these things but
there are some groups of people who I
haven't heard from that I would like to
where are all of those Second Amendment
supporters who were so vocal just a
couple of weeks
and who are so silent now when you were
asking for a tyrannical government to
fight against well now is your chance if
you stay at home thinking that the
Second Amendment is more important than
the First Amendment I feel sorry for you
and I think that you should come to the
conclusion that your fantasy of being a
good guy with a gun fighting a
tyrannical government is just that it's
just a fantasy if you were willing to
protest a few weeks ago you should be
willing to fight police abuse and
systemic violence out there today and
where are all of those freedom of
religion folks the the irony of what
happened yesterday is that in order to
clear out the protesters the federal
government used federal officers to
clear out the actual priest who was in
charge of st. George's Church and then
the president held out a Bible without
opening it without reading from it if
that's not blasphemy I don't know what
is why aren't you being vocal about this
abuse of religion for political ends and
where are all of the folks who claim to
care about law and order what we saw
last night was pure lawlessness just
because the federal government does it
doesn't mean that it should and it
doesn't mean that was legal and doesn't
mean that it was right if you care about
a rule of law that applies to everyone
you ought to be appalled at what
happened last night
and besides speaking out if you could
donate to the ACLU I'll put a link in
the description I would greatly
appreciate it I think there are a lot of
folks who are going to need some good
legal representation before all of this
is out and I will give to the ACLU as
well by now you've probably seen this
photo the lights were dark at the White
House last night but the lights have
been dark hit the White House for a long
time let's do what we can to bring the
light back
you